foreign
[Music]
good morning everybody how many for you
is this your last session or do you have
more okay we're just we're trying to
Baseline who's gonna bolt if we don't
keep your attention but uh thanks so
much for being here everyone my name is
Denise Pearl I'm part of the ecosystem
and channels organization of Google
cloud and I manage a program called
Google cloud ready sustainability so
during the show you guys may have heard
about other designations within our
partner program Google cloud ready
bigquery Google cloud ready Sovereign
Cloud these are specific designations
that we award to partners with domain or
subject matter expertise in order to
help our customers basically isolate the
right partners for the right problem and
so I'm here today joined by Mike and
Shane and I'm going to allow them to
introduce themselves and Shane I might
go to you first because just want to
point out that Deloitte is the first
Global Systems integrator that's joined
the Google cloud ready sustainability
program so I'm super thrilled to be here
with you today thank you I want to tell
them what you're up to absolutely so I
guess it's still good morning depending
on the time zone good afternoon Shane
Mulder Shane moldenhauer I'm a partner
in Deloitte Canada I lead our
sustainability and climate uh practice
specifically focused on transportation
decarbonization and I lead our asset
Factory in a sense for building
technologies that apply to our specific
client needs and one of those largest
needs is Fleet electrification
specifically so really interested to get
into that conversation a little bit more
and share on what we've been doing
wonderful and Mike you want to tell
everybody who you are and what you do
absolutely my name is Mike Branch I head
update in analytics an AI at geotab so
I've been doing that for the last six
and a half almost seven years
um and just very quickly geotab we we
process data from about you know 3.7
million connected commercial vehicles
across the globe so we're looking at
about 50 billion records coming in uh on
a daily basis across the whole ecosystem
so I'm really excited to work very
closely with the folks at Google and
Deloitte towards Fleet electrification
on my team I've got a number of data
analysts data scientists and Engineers
product folks all looking at we you know
my whole mantras it takes a village
really to raise any data and AI products
so that kind of falls under my umbrella
at geotep wonderful so what we wanted to
share with you guys today is something
that we're talking about inside my
program something called ambition loops
and the idea is that customers started
coming to I think collectively all of us
about two years ago with a really
focused conversation on sustainability
they wanted to do something in regards
to sustainability in their organization
but I think they were all asking us
where do we start what do we do and so
again we created this program inside
Google Cloud Google cloud ready
sustainability and it is this showcase
moment to Spotlight these Solutions
these industry value networks that have
come together technology systems
integration Cloud infrastructure in
order to specifically address a
particular sustainability business
problem within our mutual customers and
the one that we worked on together with
geotab and Deloitte is around Fleet
electrification we heard pretty
consistently from a lot of our mutual
customers that one of the things they
thought they could quickly do was
Electrify their Fleet and change the
sustainability position within their
organization and so we wanted to come
together today tell you a little bit
about that story and maybe give you a
few moments of introspection about this
journey Lessons Learned and things you
can can consider right moving forward so
Mike I said like you know a couple years
ago these people are coming to us
they're like hey I've been doing
telematics now I want to think about
sustainability the CEOs and CEOs and
CFOs were starting to join these Fleet
conversations and telling us like you
know the boards are asking us to do
something about our business in the
sustainability area how can how can we
do that with our Fleet we we've heard
this thing about electrification so what
were you hearing is it pretty similar
yeah a lot of the whys behind it there's
a number of reasons right
um so there's uh a number of government
incentives that exists today right to be
able to move your Fleet from Ice
Vehicles electric vehicles so that
typically is is a big incentive for
these fleets to kind of move things
forward increasingly you have
sustainability as a mandate across the
board right we're seeing Chief
sustainability officers being more and
more concerned about how they can drive
their prerogatives through
um and one of the interesting things is
if you look at where emissions are
generated from from you know buildings
from industry from vehicles
the the commercial fleets across the
globe stand such they can make such a
big impact that's right
um a third of uh you know Transportation
missions come from commercial fleets
and so unlike you or I you know I
changed my vehicle maybe once every five
maybe ten years right uh these and some
people don't even have them anymore
these fleets are changing their vehicles
sometimes on an annual basis and there's
a cycle right so as you're trying to
make that decision of you know which new
vehicles you're going to purchase let's
make them sustainable let's see how you
can move towards electric vehicles so if
you look at the ability to actually
impact change from a statement
sustainability perspective wow what an
impact you have with with commercial
fleets so there's kind of tax incentives
the government incentives there's that
sustainability approach but there's also
from an operations perspective you stand
a chance to be that much more productive
as an organization right we're seeing uh
even zero emission zones start to come
across uh the the globe where in the
future you're going to have to have one
of these EVs and so you need to start
right now and figure out how you can
make these changes so these are some of
the reasons why we're seeing folks
trying to look towards you know how can
I take my fleet right now and move
toward toward EV yeah I think that Shane
like when what Mike was just describing
you've got you know these companies that
have these corporate fleets and they're
starting to think about electrification
but that decision is is so
interconnected with the societies and
where in which we operate right like I
can't just decide to overnight Electrify
unless I've addressed EV charging
infrastructure or thought about like you
said tax incentives how am I actually
going to do all of these things and I
know that this is an area that
deloitte's been Keen to help our mutual
customers actually lay out that overall
thought leadership and plan obviously
bringing in key technology but I think
it's it's a bit more than that so if you
want to talk about what you guys have
been doing in electrified Fleet yeah for
sure so if we look at our typical
customers I say that be in three
different points of maturity along the
curve on their electrification Journey
there are those that haven't started at
all there are those that have kind of
dipped their toes in trying to figure
out what to do they bought one token
electric vehicle and they've parked it
in the garage for two three years I
haven't touched it since because you
know they don't know how to use it and
then there's the other side of it which
is we're really committed we've done it
we've got vehicles in our Fleet we've
got charging infrastructure in place and
that's exactly kind of where Deloitte
steps in is because we have all these
clients at different maturity levels
coming to us and asking us specifically
we need help
along the path either they started or
not and so we built a tool set
leveraging fantastic data that we get
from geotab in our alliance with geotab
and leveraging the power of the gcp
platform to build a tool set called
electrified Fleet that tool set has been
fundamental in bringing together very
disparate sets of data but also creating
a source of Truth which really has been
the significant key piece for helping
them feel comfortable with what we're
recommending is actually
you know they can apply it in practice
and it's sort of I I mean I hate to say
it but auditable right verifiable I
think that's such a key component part
of the Google cloud ready designate
Nation as you both know having gone
through it it's this validation that the
technology that there's domain expertise
subject matter expertise in some cases
climate science backing it and that the
the raw data informing this or the you
know transform data that will help these
companies make these decisions is again
packed and and sort of uh verified so we
really appreciate the work that you're
doing there
um I I think just for everybody in the
audience to understand I don't think
that the telematics data alone is what's
going to get us you know to full
electrification right Mike I mean when
we started helping people like you said
you can't Electrify the entire fleet
overnight right so you were saying that
some people start they often start with
a telematics question
um I'm just kind of curious like we've
obviously been in meetings where people
maybe have deployed geotab already but
some of them have not like what do you
tell customers that don't even have the
telematics data to inform it or they've
got other types of telematics data how
do you get them going yeah you know
oftentimes we always say like our
mantras you you can't manage where you
don't measure so you have to absolutely
start and and one of the things is like
it's it's nice to show studies of what
other fleets have done but the only true
way that you can know how to transform
your own sleep is by starting with
telematics right and so uh I I think by
installing you know it might be in a POC
right you start with a geotab device
combined with you know deloitte's
electrified solution it takes both the
data and the interpretation of that data
to actually transform your Fleet and
what we find is that by understanding
how your Fleet moves and what because
each Fleet is different right you've got
fleets in the government space you've
got heavy duty fleece light duty
commercial fleets they all operate
differently and you want to know what's
the potential for not just
did that archetype of a fleet to
transform but your Fleet you're
specifically so by having these devices
on your fleet vehicles monitoring how
you're moving you know how often you're
idling how often you're going on
different grades it's so crucial I mean
it really does start with the data
um and and as we've been looking at
pulling in all of this data
it's not just enough to say that you
know I'm capturing speed right or I'm
capturing you know RPM or I'm capturing
state of charge well what at what
frequency at what Fidelity all of these
things matter because you have to build
a solid foundation of data quality to be
able to do something that's right right
I mean we
um we have our electric vehicle
suitability assessment right uh which
Deloitte leverages as a tool
um in electrified and what we what we do
with that is we look at what is the
suitability of the vehicles within your
Fleet to actually move toward electric
vehicles taking into account a whole
slew of things the temperature the grade
of the road right the types of vehicles
because not every vehicle can be
electrified at this point but one of the
things that's really exciting to me is
that you know you look uh pre-pandemic
maybe around 20 or during the beginning
of the pandemic 2020 2021 we did a study
with Enterprise Fleet Management right
and it was this this Mass Electric
Vehicle suitability assessment so we
looked across their entire fleet of you
know over a hundred thousand Vehicles we
said you know what what is the
capability for us to Electrify basically
and at that point in time was about 13
of the fleet could actually move to uh
to EVS that was due to the EV
availability a whole bunch now so much
has happened since then that we ran it
again this year 45 right so there
there's such a an ability for these
fleets to start moving towards
electrification and we're going to see
more and more of that happening with the
total cost of ownership coming down for
these vehicles but you know to your
point
the data is certainly one point the
quality of the data but then it's the
interpretation and that's why working
with folks like Deloitte to help our
customers through that whole transition
phase is so important yeah I think
I'd love to give some metrics because
you I I remember that story and I think
I just watched your CEO present at the
supply chain just to double click on
this because often we get asked
questions about like how do we invest in
these projects and I think that what you
guys demonstrated even with 13 of that
Fleet there was something like a 30
million dollar operational savings
within that org over four years so I I
think that there is sort of this
perception that investing in
sustainability is somehow you know not
profitable for organizations and I think
what we're seeing is this
interconnection absolutely between
sustainability and operational
efficiency but I I think Shane you know
one of the the things that always pops
into my mind when Mike tells these
stories is like I said we in order to
make these electrification decisions it
is the vehicle it's in some cases the
load the type of vehicle the driver
Behavior the temperature it's also this
community like charging infrastructure
and like how do we I mean that's really
a big part I think of how it's extending
inside Deloitte you're not just thinking
about electrified Fleet but you're
thinking about grids and things like
that do you want more Cooks in the
kitchen exactly you want to share a
little bit more detail it is a big
decision it's a big interconnected
decision I think to make that happen
yeah it's a little bit more of a complex
question so a typical Fleet transition
is my vehicles are aging out or I'm
expanding my business procurement goes
out and buys Vehicles Whoever has the
vehicle that's the right size and that's
pretty much the consideration does it do
what I needed to do from a load
perspective or a people carrier
perspective and so now you have a
situation where you have a client saying
I want to Electrify
Fleet procurement goes out and says
wanna buy EVS it's not that easy right
there are so many different types of
vehicles you have to consider things
like range but also battery chemistry
you have to consider the operational
temperature for where you want to
operate those vehicles and then the
charging infrastructure which often
seems to be the downfall of a lot of
large corporate customers that want to
do it is because the public charging
infrastructure doesn't exist to actually
run that Fleet so now you have to kind
of roll backwards and consider well my
facilities management group might have
some ideas around what our actual
kilowatt usage is at a specific location
so if I go to them and say I want to
install you know 10 DC fast chargers
they might turn around and say that'll
kill the entire plant's usage so you
have to bring in more people into the
conversation than you usually would and
then you have you know you've got a
top-down approach as well happening
where the board is setting goals saying
we need to do X Y and Z in terms of
sustainability what does that translate
to in the fleet side and often the
response is well we don't really
necessarily know we know how much fuel
is spent and we know our vehicles travel
this far per year that's that's about
the metrics that they often have and
it's definitely not something that they
can then huge and turn around and say
you know 45 or a fleet is going to be
transitioned yeah I think what the the
real way that this comes together in my
mind is just thinking about the user
Journey the day in the life because I
think sometimes these conversations are
happening with it from a Google Cloud
perspective we're talking to Google
Cloud users and you're logging into the
Google Cloud console where none of this
data exists right but in some cases
you're very familiar with bigquery which
is where a lot of your events go I know
you're connecting into bigquery as well
for the data aggregation lots of bqgis
functionality happening there everything
happens somewhere so a lot of the
location stuff happening within bigquery
which we're very grateful for and then
of course you guys for the most part
geotab for a lot of years has been
speaking to the fleet managers right and
so but like Shane's talking about when
you start talking about procurement
board level decisions Etc we really
needed that election certified fleet
layer that dashboard where different
teams can interact with the data not
have to be an expert in bigquery or in
Fleet Management so it's I I just I
would love for you to talk a little bit
more Shane about like what what the user
experience is when they log into
electrified Fleet like what kind of
things what different types of users
would be connecting there and what types
of decisions can they make well actually
what I'll do is I'll tell you a bit
about a client story that we have
because it'll kind of translate this or
give people a connection point to it we
have a really large customers of ours
pure later in Canada it's a last mile
delivery company they are a long-term
geotab customer and have had you know
telematics in their Fleet for the
longest time they had a board level
decision made that they had to reduce
their gear nascarian missions I think it
was like 60 percent or that they had to
reduce no sorry 40 that reduce their
Fleet for their or for the leader for
the entire organization
which on paper translated to 60 of their
Fleet had to be switched to electric
vehicles so now you have I think it's
almost 5 000 vehicles that have to be
changed
or considered to be changed to electric
vehicles
step one is which vehicles should I
consider which could even because these
are not your typical passenger car their
you know class two Vans class three vans
um and the supply chain is really
constrained the charging requirements
for these are very difficult to
passenger vehicle so they came to the
light and asked Can you guys support us
on our journey we know that you have a
tool set available to do exactly that so
we went in and did a full evaluation of
all other fleets so we looked at a
six-month period of data including the
ambient temperature so we did a bit of a
season from
um kind of
winter into spring so we could see the
temperature variances for the entire
operations across all the country
and it was really interesting to see
because the initial ninja reaction when
we gave them the data was well these
locations make sense let's do it but
then when we brought the facilities team
in they said well all of these are
actually old buildings they don't have
the ability to do that so now we have to
start planning into our facilities team
so you have
electrified Fleet is broken into four
different personas you have your Fleet
your Fleet operations and Fleet
procurement core people you have your
sustainability people that consider what
are the impacts and which kind of
vehicles would have what impact across
your greenhouse gas emissions reduction
and then you have your business side so
your financial planning because one of
the outputs is a seven year procurement
plan so which charges do I need to buy
exactly by when and how do I kind of
space that out with procurement of
vehicles because some of the DC fast
charges the lead time is eight months
but some of these commercial vehicles
the lead time is 12 months so you almost
have to buy the vehicles and then the
infrastructure but neither arrive for a
very long time and so it's been
interesting and then the last one is is
the pure Facilities Management side
these are the sites we've identified
this is how many Chargers and then they
kind of give us inputs around this is
our current capacity constraint for this
location what can you do with that
charging infrastructure and then how can
we put the vehicles into them as well so
it's multiple different personas that
project was a huge success we supported
them in identifying exactly how many
vehicles to transition and we're happy
to say that they're going to be removing
about 80 000 tons of greenhouse gases
from their Fleet over the next few years
so that's uh
very nice it's a great story yeah
because it tells it it's exactly what we
have seen from all of our customers it's
like we haven't I we have a board level
decision we have a fleet that doesn't
necessarily know where to start they
knew what they needed to do they already
acquired some Vehicles they were testing
it pure later is very Progressive around
their green strategy and but they still
needed that support on like how do I how
do I do this by 2030 because they have
Ambitions to be completely Net Zero by
2050. that's right yeah it is
interesting because we we see these like
public commitments about Net Zero trans
you know transition and I think these
board members feel obligated or c-level
executive feel obligated the consumers
the customers are asking for it but then
when you go back down into the org and
try to understand all of the data that's
required to actually get you to Net Zero
oftentimes in Old traditional ways of
aggregating data or viewing data the old
sheets way of doing everything what you
find out is by the time I could view all
the data that I need I've already missed
my 2030 goal so I think you know using
the power of cloud to aggregate all of
that data you mentioned both of you have
said about weather yeah and it's been
interesting to me in the program that I
support just how often people ask for
weather because it's such an incredible
impact on some of these decisions that
we make you know both like the
efficiencies of vehicles and then the
charging infrastructure itself so yeah
Mike I think one thing that I'd love to
double click on with the fleet managers
if there's any of them in the audience
are watching right because these are the
people that you've been coaching up
Shane just mentioned all of these other
external people that are going to be
calling them for help what would you
suggest us that they think about as they
start to grow and update their
telematics infrastructure their Fleet
Management Solutions yeah no I think
again the the focus on on data quality
is so important and
um you know at geotab we have
um we're connected to uh we have we have
Engineers who are consistently reverse
engineering getting the right signals
from the EVS that exist out there we
have new EVS being introduced into the
market uh every single day right and so
um for for data quality to be really
good you have to be able to extract
these signals whether that come from the
vehicle itself or from an oem Cloud to
Cloud connection so as you're thinking
about that that transition to EV to
sustainable I think very very carefully
about not just whether you're getting a
signal what Fidelity what is the shape
of that so how good is the data quality
that you're getting from the vehicle
that is so so so Paramount right
um and then yeah we leverage a ton of
Google Cloud to be able to process this
data at scale right you think about the
data coming in from the vehicles right
GPS data at scale marrying that and
snapping it to the right roads to make
sure that you can understand the grade
pulling in temperature data as well too
right so we've got the ambient
temperature coming in from you know 3.7
million commercial vehicles so we have
hyper local temperature and weather
location but you're snapping that all to
this road Network so we leverage you
know Google bigquery bqgis and all this
stuff and pull that all together I think
bqml as well bqml as well too yeah
um but yeah the whole stack is really
built on on gcp Kafka kubernetes to pump
everything into that big query platform
and then really excited about a lot of
the work being done now on vertex Ai and
and how we're taking that to the next
step in leveraging gender Beyond yeah
there were these questions I think
coming up you know we start to think
about gen AI the ability to actually
inspect this type of telematics data and
ask questions like which one of my
vehicles are you know the largest
producers of carbon emissions or things
like that and then you can sort of again
I think one of the things to take away
from this value network of the people
sitting on the stage here is again you
know directly being a BQ consumer
hearing things like bqgis and bqml some
of these terms I think for Fleet people
could seem a little abstract so it's so
wonderful to have a company like geotab
that's just built on top of it produce
this my geotab layer so you can actually
just see the things you need to see
right and you don't have to be
necessarily an infrastructure and the
partnership that's why I think the
partner that's these industry value
networks the partnership amongst the
three here has been what's allowed us to
accelerate right think any one component
wouldn't have allowed pure later to
achieve that that dream right absolutely
but you have all three components
together in that value
so I I'd love to just kind of and we
want to save some time for questions
from the audience but I would love to
ask you both like um again maybe uh if
you were to give one two one or two
pieces of guidance Mike or just lessons
learned from your point of view I think
um don't be afraid to start now right
and start with collecting it because you
may you may not be able to transition to
EVS as a fleet right now just because of
vehicle availability but what you can do
is start your journey towards
transportation decarbonization and that
may come from you know reducing idling
in certain areas by changing driver
Behavior right on maybe class eight
heavy duty Vehicles where the charging
infrastructure isn't there necessarily
to support that
um but yeah start now make sure that
you're collecting the right data because
that's going to inform all of your
future decisions and there's nothing
stopping you from starting now just
because the EVS don't necessarily exist
for your affiliate there's other ways
that you can move towards Transportation
decarbonization it's such a great way a
frame
that work in general inside companies
and just like sometimes it's a team of
one yesterday I was on the stage with
the chief sustainability officer from
Palo Alto networks and we were talking
about them collecting sustainability
information across their org and I said
well Vince you know your team he goes
what do you mean
I don't have a team it's me but he said
I have these people throughout the
organizations which you know Logistics
is going to be one of those contributors
he said I have this community that's
been established across the org and
they're now starting to work with their
data with this lens right and what we
see which is really fascinating amongst
again just I think our community of
sustainability leaders people in our
companies want to help so I I love what
you said we recently did a Harris poll
inside Google across 1500 Executives
specific to sustainability because I
think one of the other questions that
we're getting right now is with all the
economic headwinds everything that's
going on are people still working on
sustainability does it still matter and
I think what we saw was although
sustainability went down in ranking it's
still in the top three the other
interesting thing that came out of that
study was that they may not say
sustainability they say supply chain
resilience they say adaptability right
they say viability and so uh you know
just thinking about that as we show up
together and talking and Servicing all
of our mutual customers I think we have
to be listening for those other keywords
and then like you said individually
looking at the data that we have and
thinking about how we can apply it to
these new use cases Shane I'd ask the
same from you like what uh what Lessons
Learned would you offer to everyone I
think Mike's on the right track which is
start now
um they're collecting good data is going
to help you because it sort of the
source of Truth really is the critical
piece that gets buy-in from the rest of
the business talked about the
auditability Assurance piece like
knowing what is being recommended starts
with having a good set of data we often
find a lot of our clients you know you
talk about the the CSO having it being a
team of one but having Champions around
him and I think it's going to be the
same for the Journey of decarbonization
that people will start growing but they
all will have disparate pieces of data
to input kind of bring to the table but
I think it starts with a good data set
it starts with and and honestly like
I've been working with geotab for a good
number of years now fantastic product it
does stand Above the Rest in terms of
data quality right and so for company
like ourselves it needs to have that
trust it it's it's really good working
with the part-time that we can trust the
data all the time and know that what's
coming out is is is literally what
happened so the vehicle did do this
exact motion
um these were the emissions this was the
odometer and the external temperature so
um building platforms on top of that for
us also uh but start with start now
start with the data collect some
information at the very least you know
to your point you can start with other
decarbonization activities like idle
reduction driver training programs those
are gonna move the needle that's right
and collect all the
Roman tool yeah the
the up and said okay it's still
important they said you know we're a bit
hesitant to come out with these public
commitments like we used to be because
we did it we didn't have the data to
support it we got some backlash from our
consumers from our customers so now
we're a little nervous about stepping
forward and the the last question that I
think Google really reinforced what can
we do to help and they said give us
tools to measure it give us tools where
we can go verify it and I think
aspirationally that ask makes sense I
also think what we're seeing from a
regulatory structure is it's it is you
know sustainability data and financial
data they're intersecting and the same
obligation of how you do financial
reporting and how you do sustainability
reporting they really are coming
together so like you said I one of the
stories that Mike shared with me about
the different Fidelity of geotab
telematics that I love was when we talk
about driver swerving because I used to
commute a lot right and you were like
hey if you had another telematics
provider that that person could be
swerving in the road right going 80
miles an hour swerve but come back in
and have really appropriate behavior you
don't have the right telematics that's
clicking out you know on a second by
second basis connected to all those
systems you would have missed it and you
know what it seemed it seems so uh maybe
simple and trivial oh yeah what if I
miss a couple uh points here and there
but it makes a huge difference yeah
especially across 3.8 million exactly
adding this stuff up at scale and so the
way that we just for those who aren't
aware the way we kind of tackle our our
data collection is through curve logic
right so we're not necessarily capturing
data every second or every two seconds
or every five seconds it's on these
these error bar thresholds right so if
I'm driving down the highway or the or
the freeway you notice at a specific
speed I'm going to be collecting fewer
points but if I happen to like jam on
the acceleration pedal and you know
overpass and collecting more points
along the way so
um it's based very much on these air
thresholds those are so critical for
data and especially in this world of you
know generative AI where Data Trust and
data quality is so important people want
to know what actually did happen people
are making decisions purchasing
decisions hiring despite this like there
are some serious decisions people are
making based on this data and you have
to get the quality right so to that
point we do spend a lot of time on data
quality from the vehicle all the way
through to the Myriad of pipelines that
we have running
to get the data that is required to make
these decisions and if you look at the
broader impact on sustainability and
carbon inventory that companies or GSG
inventory the companies have to now
submit to regular Regulators the SEC
whoever the body or local tax
authorities are these things matter
that's right like if you get it wrong
there is actually going to be a Fallout
if it is not correct I told everybody I
feel like we're at that sarbanes-oxley
moment for us in sustainability where
it's starting to become very legitimate
but you guys thank you so much for all
of the information that you provided I
hope these were great examples I'd love
to leave a few minutes for questions
here before I let you stand up though I
did want to let you know there's a
survey we'd love to get your feedback
love to hear if these stories matter to
you if these ambition Loops that we're
describing right if you can take action
on them so please provide us some
feedback but if there's any questions
and I will tell you that you gotta lean
into that mic for us to be able to hear
you so we'd love to see Chad I know I
can always count on you for a good
question we don't get it thank you so
much
lean in there I'm not kidding hello um
you gave an anecdote of a company who uh
was looking to Electrify and you
initially gave them a number I think it
was in the low teens you said and then
later you uh revised that number to be
in maybe it was the 40s can you
elaborate more on what led to that large
increase in the recommendation was that
battery capacity or vehicle availability
be it primarily vehicle availability is
what that is what led to it right and so
it's specific to that company would you
say that just a larger trend for across
I think it's the worst thing that is a
larger Trend so what we did it wasn't
just for that company so if you look at
you know Enterprise Fleet Management
it's a it's a cross that the entire
space over 100 000 Vehicles went into
that study so it's not just one customer
but it's across the entire kind of um a
hold of vehicles there and so from about
20 20 to 2023 that's because of vehicle
availability
you were able to see that that increase
yeah thank you
thank you for the question yeah thank
you
hey good good morning
um so just quick comment maybe not
necessarily question or maybe partially
question is and you brought up the point
like start small maybe with um idle time
reductions Based on telematic data or
maybe route planning or you know there's
probably there's dozens of ways but the
other thing that you didn't really hit
on and I think is also important is the
Scopes two and three reductions by
making the choices you'll make with
electrifying your Fleet or maybe even
you know going hybrid for your Fleet so
because those especially if you're going
to talk about reporting and meeting
sustainability goals for your
organization
uh you know full life cycle emissions
for example or your Scopes two and three
are going to also make an impact and
that will you know the decisions you
make on your Fleet will impact your
Scopes two and three yeah and it goes
along thanks for the question it goes
along the line of the broader
sustainability goals that institutions
have so look at a company like Walmart a
lot of their providers they're not
considering their suppliers uh scope two
emissions as their scope three emissions
and they're actually going with
providers that have the ability to give
them that data as a source of Truth and
really be able to tell that story around
how the supply chain impacts somebody
like Walmart scope three so yes it you
know within the work that I do a lot
with other carbon inventory programs
stop thinking about electrification
decarbonization whatever it is as just a
pure cost center there is a profit
Center not just necessarily monetarily
right now but if you look at EV
operations over time cost of operating
in EV Fleet reduces over time but
there's other things carbon taxes in the
future that might impact you as well but
there's a brand reputation that goes
with it as well if you start making that
commitment to decarbonize your Fleet
your fleet's often the first thing that
people see about you you're on the
highways you're driving around you have
branded vehicles that impacts your
shareholders uh view on you as well so
yeah scope T scope 2 in terms of your
business and how you operate that Fleet
let's go through in terms of how that
data impacts others is is significantly
important as well
I might add local head please
sir and with larger organizations you
know scope three for example
and on an individual level is very small
but when you get a large Fleet you know
that scope 3 is going to add up very
quickly and certainly should be part of
your reporting yeah I think I think one
of the things to go look at potentially
as well and again partnership with with
Deloitte is from a Google perspective we
are also thinking about uh just
modernization of the grid because a big
part of the dependency here is like just
do we have the grid infrastructure to
support it Google itself is like we're
in our third decade right of working on
climate action and and we were really
focused on data center efficiency so you
know obviously we went 100 renewable but
now we're working towards carbon free
and what Google is thinking about is
like in order for our data centers to be
truly 7 by 24 by 365 green energy We've
Got to Now inject Capital perhaps into
these areas where our data centers will
be right to build out solar wind
geothermal Etc we have to work with the
utilities in order to Green up the
accessibility to this energy and this
all impacts the charging infrastructure
which is a dependency for you so again I
think within Google Cloud at least
within our program we're bringing some
of those energy
you know providers the flexi Dows the
rent energies the electricity Maps level
tens right all of those are
participating in Google cloud ready
sustainability as well and we'll be
showing up in like future Solutions you
know that are coming out from Deloitte
around like electrified grid and things
like that so they'll all come together
like Shane said because I think I've had
a lot of chats here at this the show
about scope three
really hard really really hard and I
think we just have to address it with
humility and I think that the number one
thing I take away is it that we all as
individual organizations clean up our
act around scope one and scope two then
we all clean up each other's scope three
right so great question thank you so
much just to build on that a little bit
as well too you know you also have to
look at the power of this data at scale
so some of the things the work that
we're we're doing uh within our geotab
intelligent Transportation Systems line
of business is taking this aggregate
data at scale anonymized working with
folks like uh National Grid to look at
the Confluence of okay well I need to
understand where the high voltage power
lines are coming and I need to
understand truck movement patterns to be
able to properly position charging
infrastructure for the future as well
too so it's not only at the individual
Fleet level but now how do you take this
data at scale aggregate privacy
compliant work with you know the grid to
be able to figure out you know what does
that deployment of the charging
infrastructure need to look like so very
excited to continue to work with
Deloitte and this is where all the
bigquery nerds in the room were like I
could join this table with this table
with this table right chat and ask that
question so thank you so I see my friend
Nick right yes yes how are you
um I wanted to ask if you could speak a
little bit more to how you bridge the
gap between uh board or executive
mandates and individual employee buy-in
and in particular what role data and
analytics plays in that such a great
question it's a great question
um I'll take one one stab at it so one
of the things that I've always been a
huge proponent of is like get the data
out of Fleet right like so often our
customers are the fleet managers and our
mission is to get outside of the fleet
organization and to the board level to
make sure that the right decisions can
be made I mean there are a few tactics
from a technology perspective that we're
using to try and enable that and the
goal is to get it into the systems The
Business Systems within those
organizations that those Executives rely
upon on a daily basis so um simple
things that you can do from a technology
perspective is make sure it's easily
integratable right so you know we've got
data connectors that that take that data
from our Fleet platform and move it into
all sorts of bi platforms that the
organization is already using so that
those those c-suite Executives who are
looking at these dashboards or who have
these dashboards displayed to them
they're not five steps removed from the
data which exists in the fleet platform
right so getting it into the Enterprise
data strategy for these larger
organizations is one thing that is going
to highlight the importance of the data
at the c-suite that's only one step but
that's something that I've found has
started to resonate more and more
I think I think you know I'll just
reinforce what I what I keep saying I I
feel like uh you know obviously I run a
program that's called Google cloud ready
sustainability and I think a lot of
times when c-level Executives hear that
they put me in a certain category you
know the projects that I'm going to work
on the impact that we're going to have
the things that we're doing but when you
approach them and you start to talk more
about long-term viability of the
organization right and it depends on
what company you work for but I would
say that across the board every
organization that we talk to is
concerned in one way or another about
raw materials for their products they're
concerned about logistics they're
concerned about you know climate impacts
to their organization and so I think we
we collectively as a group need to get
better at translating that
sustainability actually means
operational impact to these businesses
right and it's people like you that that
live and breathe this right that know
what's happening within your org you're
bringing a sustainability lens to it and
you're providing that translation if you
can take what Mike said about the data
that exists in the fleet put it into a
business system and actually produce a
report that says you know hey we could
potentially save millions of dollars by
electrifying our Fleet you know through
you know operational savings carbon
emissions reductions or whatever that
that to me is a sustainability story but
what an executive hears their right is
like operational efficiency I'm
performing for my shareholders Etc so
that would be some of my feedback what
about you Shane yeah I think I mean
getting the data out is critical
um not just putting it into bi platforms
but also putting it into your Erp
systems to be able to start having
people held accountable for some of the
commitments that they're making
um is is key there's some great
connectors the lights built as well for
sap article workday those kinds of
platforms
um that definitely can support that I
at the end of the day there's a lot of
upskilling that has to be done in
Education that has to be done on what
this data means and what the impact is
across businesses for sustainability for
you know Capital Performance is a bunch
of different areas but yeah
great question thank you
and Chad
oh you know we're all in trouble right
yeah thanks Dee's for adding me for a
question so uh I do have one and we've
talked a lot about some happy things
like hey this is the you know lean in
Chad the operational efficiency that you
get or the savings that you get
sustainability gains you get but I
wanted to ask about some uh unhappy
things because when you think about the
energy transmission lines all the way
from generation to consumption like
transmission lines Just Energy
Distribution Systems and whatnot if you
create a lot more Demand by positioning
a network of charging stations around
now the you know the energy companies
have to supply those and then the
transmission supplies have to supply the
energy companies Etc
so where does the story get
sad again like where's the are there
bottlenecks between energy generation
and consumption what's the next problem
that we need to be thinking about
assuming we've solved all of the stuff
that we've talked about here which we
haven't but what's the next one that we
got to worry about great resilience yeah
and I think Chad it's such a great
question because like I said when we did
start to think about out you know going
out and making recommendations about
electrification it naturally led us to
exactly what you're talking about we're
actually we could in some cases be
setting people up for a non-satisfactory
experience because they actually can't
get to electrification right just simply
because of the grid infrastructure but
inside Google as you know we've been
working on 24x7 clean energy and we
didn't do that alone we've been working
with various Partners again uh thinking
through partners that do actual
um in some cases the first place to
start in my mind is to actually make
more energy available full stop is
probably just to optimize what we're
already using
so going into major energy intensive
assets and evaluating them again through
data and saying can I just get them to
perform better use less energy which
frees up energy for the rest of us
that's point one the second point is
maybe start to talk to the utilities in
a different way about how they collect
data meter data management Etc about how
utilities are actually working a lot of
them don't even understand the scope or
the requirements of the green balance on
the grid so maybe optimization of these
high energy intensive assets work with
utilities to get better visibility into
the brown green balance and then start
to move people onto this conversation
about Renewables I think that Google's
journey is a great one for people to
watch because we had that problem right
like we wanted to make our data centers
you know we wanted to have this amazing
story about energy reduction and
potentially 100 renewable but when we
went out and looked at where our
existing data centers were and where we
wanted to build it didn't exist so
Google actually had to go out and do
capital investment actually support the
build out of solar wind geothermal to
support our own facilities and part of
that frankly wasn't just Capital
infusion it was policy we had to go work
with local policy makers to make sure
that if we actually dispatched this
green energy could we buy it again
interconnection with the utilities and
then I think once that happens you start
to understand okay I've got the
renewable energy sort of build out
happening which is accelerating and I
think you guys are tracking a lot of
that at Deloitte and then the final
piece is now I start acquiring the
renewable energy and we start to get
that balance and so outside of this work
although they're interconnected we have
this carbon free energy Journey
happening with a bunch of other partners
that are feeding into something like
electrified grid from Deloitte which
should hopefully continue the story chat
but it's such a great one that you raise
and it goes to the scope 2 and scope
three right scope one we may be able to
solve for I can't solve for scope two
and so I start cleaning up the grids
like you're mentioning so excellent
excellent observation and hopefully that
a bit more detail you know is provide
you a bit of hope that we're thinking
through it but Shane I know like I said
I see Jamie in the audience this
electrification of the grid is a big
deal for you guys yeah it's a huge
concern for us again the cleaning of the
grid immigrant well cleaning of the
great great resilience ensuring that as
we make recommendations for
electrification and decarbonization we
don't inadvertently actually create a
problem and so we've been working
tirelessly with some of the local
utilities across Canada and and in the
US as well to understand where they are
and so grid planning happens 50 years
out but if you look at the curve for
technology adoption and electricity
usage we're actually a little bit
disconnected from those 50-year plans
and so we're trying to support them in
that aspect of let's bring multiple data
sets the its platform of geotabs are
fantastically important one because it
gives us an understanding of
Transportation corridors once you start
getting into you know DC fast charging
of heavy trucks that's going to put a
massive draw on on networks and usually
there's not a significant Supply along
large Transportation corridors because
there's gas stations you don't have to
think about that so all of these pieces
inform a new asset where we've developed
called electrified grid which does
exactly that takes into consideration
things like heat pump adoption
um like renewable use transportation
electrification and helps them plan from
the endpoint so building endpoint all
the way back into the distribution
center and transmission Network to
figure out where the failure points
that's right that will occur along the
line well you guys this has been a
fantastic conversation full disclosure
these are two of the best partners that
I work with every day and so it's great
to be on stage with you
um thank you so much for the audience
participation we hope you enjoyed the
content and enjoy the last day of next
thank you
[Applause]